thank you AWS for sponsoring this video
okay picture this it's a typical Monday
morning and as a cloud architect you're
gearing up for the week ahead your
company has just launched a new lineup
of eco-friendly shoes to the public and
things are looking pretty good but then
something unexpected happens the shoes
become so popular that your company's
servers are here with a huge surge of
traffic that they aren't able to handle
customer complaints start pouring in
tickets begin to pile up and develop as
a scrambling to patch things together
the pressure is on and you find yourself
in the middle of it thankfully you and
your team managed to fix the issue just
in time but a few hours later the
manager Taps you on the shoulder and
needs you to find a solution to help
prevent these situations from happening
again what I just described is one of
the many situations that cloud
developers and Architects face from time
to time it's part of the job and can
sometimes feel like you're on a
firefighting Mission but what if I told
you that there's a way to minimize these
types of situations or even better stop
them from happening in the first place
hey everyone this is Lucy and in this
video we're going to explore the AWS
well architected framework something
that could completely change the way you
build things on the cloud this framework
will help you tackle and prevent common
cloud computing challenges so make sure
you stick around if you want to build
Cloud systems that are prepared for
anything that comes in their way so the
AWS World architect the framework to put
it simply is a set of strategies and
guidelines for Designing and running
workloads in the cloud it's created by
AWS and provides a framework to help
Cloud Architects build resilient
architectures now this framework doesn't
just provide you with a list of do's and
don'ts instead it gives you a blueprint
and guideline for building resilient
scalable and secure applications and
workloads essentially taking the
guesswork out of building things in the
cloud it also provides a consistent
approach for AWS customers and partners
to evaluate their architectures and this
helps them create designs that will
scale with application designs over time
okay now you might be wondering why is
it important for me to understand this
framework well let's think back to the
scenario from the start of the video
without proper planning and architecting
companies could get easily blindsided by
sudden changes to their infrastructure
for example when there's a sudden surge
of traffic the result system crashes
unhappy customers and countless numbers
of hours spent on damage control in our
digital age any downtime or disruption
can not only cost companies a lot of
money but can also cause damage to
reputation and loss of customer trust
and that's why building resilient
architectures is no longer a choice but
rather a necessity understanding and
applying the AWS World architecture
framework can help you avoid common
pitforce decrease your risk and pretty
much just make sure your applications
are well architected it's also important
to note that this framework is the
result of years of Real World Experience
from people designing and managing
workloads in the cloud when you
understand and use the AWS World
architecture framework you're
essentially tapping into the combined
knowledge of countless Cloud architects
who have faced similar issues and have
figured out ways to effectively mitigate
them and so by understanding and
implementing the framework you're not
just leveraging AWS expertise but also
making sure your systems can handle real
world scenarios it's kind of like having
a road map for architecture in the cloud
that sets you up for success to give you
a better idea of what the world
architecture framework looks like here
are the six main pillars that the
framework is built around so the first
one is security and then there's cost
optimization performance efficiency
sustainability reliability and
operational excellence and these pillars
are more than just buzzwords each one
focuses on a specific component that
contributes to a well architected Cloud
setup by following these best practices
you can architect for high availability
plan for business continuity and so on
okay so firstly the security pillar
focuses on protecting your data systems
and assets this includes confidentiality
of data identity and access management
as well as establishing controls to
detect security threats the next pillar
is cost optimization this is all about
avoiding unnecessary cost it's about
using the right types of resources for
your workloads and making cost-effective
decisions over long term performance
efficiency is all about using compute
resources efficiently to meet system
requirements and maintaining that
efficiency as demand changes and
Technologies evolve and the
sustainability plr focuses on minimizing
environmental impact whilst running
Cloud workloads now let's zoom into the
remaining two pillars operational
excellence and reliability these two
pillars are very important because they
provide you with architectural best
practices and guidance to improve the
resilience of your workloads so starting
with the operational excellence pillar
this is about running and monitoring
systems to deliver business value and
continuity the goal here is not only to
have a system that's efficient and
reliable but also one that improves over
time here are the design principles for
the operational excellence pillar the
first one is perform operations as code
so what does this mean think of your
entire workload as you would a piece of
software by turning your operations into
scripts and automating them we can
reduce mistakes that come with human
error and create predictable responses
whenever certain events occur the second
one is to make frequent small reversible
changes for this one the aim is to make
changes in small steps that can be
undone if needed this approach helps
deal with issues quickly without any
major effects to your customers the next
one is refine operation procedures
frequently now this is all about
constant Improvement as your workload
evolves your procedures should evolve
with it always be on the lookout for
ways to refine and streamline your
operations next up we have anticipate
failure so instead of waiting for things
to go wrong try to identify the possible
failures before they occur and by
regularly testing these scenarios you
can better understand the impact and
then ensure that the response procedures
are kept up to date lastly we have
learned from operational failures every
operational event or failure is a
learning opportunity so don't shy away
from them instead use these lessons to
help you build stronger and more
resilient systems you could also share
this knowledge across the different
teams so that they can learn from each
other next let's dive into the
reliability pillar this one focuses is
on the ability of a system to recover
from disruptions dynamically meet
demands and mitigate disruptions here
are the design principles for the
reliability pillar the first one is
automatically recover from failure this
principle simply means to monetize
imported metrics closely I use
automation to fix issues as soon as they
occur in other words your system bounces
back automatically when something goes
wrong the second one is to test recovery
procedures this principle suggests that
we should actively test how our system
handles failure in practice this means
using automation to simulate frequent
failure scenarios to make sure that
recovery plans work as intended next up
we have horizontal scale to increase
aggregate workload availability with
this principle the goal is to spread our
workload across multiple smaller
resources that way if one part fails
it's not going to shut down everything
another principle to reliability is to
stop guessing capacity this means that
we should monitor exactly how much our
systems are being used and adjust our
resources accordingly so the goal here
is to have just as much resources as you
need no more no less and finally we have
managed change through automation for
this one it's all about automating any
changes to our infrastructure this
method helps keep everything consistent
easily trackable and smooth running to
give you an example of how the
reliability and operational excellence
pillars are used let's take company a
for example company a is an online store
that sells watches they recently
launched a new set of watches that
thousands of people around the world
wanted to buy resulting in a huge surge
of web traffic this is how they handle
the situation so whenever the new
watches were added to the online catalog
an automated system will trigger all the
necessary systems to update they also
had real-time monitoring tools to track
and respond to any issues so that if
there was an error in the system they
would be notified right away so thanks
to the operational excellence pillar
they were able to navigate this search
without any issues but what about
whether the even bigger surge in traffic
for example during the holiday season
when people are buying watches for their
friends and family that's where the
reliability pillar comes in company a
designed their systems that it
dynamically handles increased load by
automatically scaling their Cloud
infrastructure so if a server fails a
backup server immediately kicks in
keeping the online store accessible and
so by adopting the operational
excellence and reliability pillars from
the world architecture framework company
a was able to build an efficient and
reliable system capable of delivering a
seamless shopping experience for their
customers to get started with the AWS
World architecture framework you can
check out the link in the description
below that directs you straight to the
AWS World architected landing page here
you'll find out more about the six
pillars and you can access detailed
documentation on each of them but yeah
overall I think it's a great resource
for developers Solutions Architects and
anyone working with Cloud infrastructure
it's very user friendly and is available
completely for free so I'd recommend
visiting the website to learn more and
try it out for yourselves okay so this
wraps up our deep dive into the AWS
World architecture framework the key
takeaway is that it's not just a set of
documentation or guidelines it's almost
like a long-term companion to advise you
on how to build robust scalable and
secure systems in the cloud if you found
this video helpful please remember to
give it a like and let me know your
thoughts on this framework in the
comments below alright bye for now